les médecins spécialistes québécois
gagnent en moyenne rantissi 1000 $ de
plus que leurs collègues ontariens
c'est du moins ce que révèlent les plus
récents chiffres de l'institut canadien
d'information sur la santé selon le
classement de l'institut avec un revenu
moyen d'environ 400 3000 $ les médecins
spécialistes du québec grimpe sur la
troisième marche du podium derrière les
médecins spécialistes du yukon et ceux
de l'île du prince édouard et comme on
aime toujours comparer le salaire des
médecins du québec avec ceux de
l'ontario et bien dites vous que les
ontariens arrive au 6e rang avec un
revenu moyen de 367 1000 $ soit comme on
le disait trente six mille dollars de
moins que les spécialistes québécois
pour votre information voici le
classement des spécialités médicales les
mieux rémunérés au québec selon la régie
d'assurance maladie au premier rang les
radiologistes avec plus de 690 7000 $
arrivent ensuite les ophtalmologistes
avec tout près de 600 96 mille dollars
ils sont suivis des chirurgie
cardio-vasculaire thoracique qui le
touche environ six à vingt-quatre mille
dollars
[Musique]